[Music]
i read an interview you said and i don't
think it's true that you said you've
always had a thing for older men is that
yes oh yes
[Applause]
i was born in 1917.
i was friends with the kaiser
is that really true though you always
always have always in fact as a as a kid
i like older boys
not that much older but but uh but
now i i just love older men i like
george clooney george cooney yeah i like
that there's a guy who's really good at
lying about his age yeah
you um is this true that you play in a
uh a regular poker game you've been this
is a poker game that you've been in for
a long time it's a 50 year old poker
game
wait for 50 years for 50 years bob
stewart who is the the game show maven
he invented he created
a password to tell the truth
all the game goods and toddman game
shows all date back to bob well bob has
been running this poker game for
as i say over 50 years i think the only
reason that i'm still allowed to play
we have the same gang is that i i put up
the money every guy i lost five dollars
last saturday you lost
so we're not talking about big you know
big big money here sounds big to me
[Laughter]
so inflation hasn't kicked in with this
poker game at all not with this folk
again okay you've stayed all right well
that sounds like a lot of fun but it's
great fun and we do laugh a lot
the um
i want to talk to you about dr seuss the
lorax
and this is this movie is uh it's got a
very nice message this movie a terrific
message it's a environmentally conscious
dolores it's about trees and how we're
well
we're losing them
terribly and
it's a it's a beautiful story and i
think one that the kids are going to
love and i think they're going to want
to see again and again it's it's just
beautiful we have a clip here and uh
this is a scene uh that that you voice a
character where you're you're pretending
to be a little out of it but you're
really you're really not your character
i go through life that way yeah
let's take a look at this clip from uh
dr seuss the lorax
so
mom
do you happen to know
if there's like any place where i could
get a real
tree you'd need to find the once-ler
the what mom
it's not really the time for any uh you
know magical fables okay oh that's right
i forgot
i'm old and can't even remember to put
my teeth in stand down that's not what i
meant no really i forgot my teeth
would you be a deer and go get them for
me
your mom
okay here's the deal the once-ler is the
man who knows what happened to the trees
you want one you need to find him
it looks fantastic too the
this is uh
it's in 3d is this is this your first
time in in 3d yes i think so
and i was thinking i'd like to do 3d
live
okay think what it can do
[Applause]